Laurie Lachlan Rachel Smith joins us
from New York and this is not a good
sign for her Rachel no it is not
Nichelle because the longest sentence
yet in the college bribery scandal just
got handed damn good Laurie becoming
unhinged after hearing that an exec was
sentenced to six months in prison for
bribing and faking photos that his kid
was on an athletic team Laurie and her
husband are accused of basically the
same thing and still maintain their
innocence meantime another mom who's
been to prison is offering Laurie advice
real housewife Teresa Giudice served 11
months and has been raising her
daughters alone now for three years what
is some advice that you might have for
Laurie and her family women are strong
we have babies we do it all I'm sure
whatever outcome it is I'm sure she'll
be fine with that she's a mom of two
daughters how should she prepare them
just be open with them and and whatever
the outcome is it is we have to deal
with it and move forward Teresa just
visited her husband Joe who was in Italy
awaiting a deportation hearing in the
u.s. following his release after 41
months in prison how was the reunion
with Joe and Italy happy tears
it was just like I was so overwhelmed
seeing how happy my daughter's were he
has leaned up yeah he's definitely not
juicy anymore how long was he a nice
seven months I mean there was people
cutting themselves in there cutting the
wrist cutting their throats you know it
was a really bad bad conditions despite
Joe's release there is a lot of tension
it's embarrassing
I do have to address the cheating rumors
you don't think she's been faithful Joe
I don't think so
do I feel like he was faithful yeah no
way I never caught him he said no
nothing happened so you know I believed
um obviously because we still stayed
together and of course you can follow
all the drama on the Real Housewives of
New Jersey Wednesday nights on Bravo
[Music]